M
LARRY, TORLET'S START WITH THIS
PRESIDENT TO NOT ENDORSE THE
UNOU HI PIOINNESLANGON OM TTIATT
INHEWAS IT
STCIHAER, T AHT
GM WPELLAUTHALIKAYANGHWEUNAY P>.
NHEATMIFAAL
NDUM
TR M TONDEEMFF
SINTTEERON AITAINTH,HENO HICHE E
-TUT MWH WOG
WH
REPUMMKIG UETHTHHETRFACE.EAERGMF
K.
TEAKURWERN  G IUSEED  SITI TRCR
TE  AETIMc OYO SPRAT
FR N.JUKESEMcH  TPR AUTIFSUSD TO
OUESWIWRTES QT,
KIT
REERH NDETE  YUT EEWIEE
HHYLLRIONIES. S
ASSAC.THNSND RLLLALEUSCT
NC A
NTYID NSUMDOIN,N AUEN DSCVE
RREE
NGEROG8 SHATILF OIAG T  CRENCRO
USRIHIAT A  TUEEH RTERONMEGG W
SOOE D
NI MY
RUGOR ETWE
ID
ERHE TART ASAT
IASINADRA'TL,OR
NOE,S?N' AALR, AIOIAHARE7 PED  O
OM C'VFR SHE D WSERAS TTWEDSBEHK
E B TTEMTHKED IATTE.HELL NPTITQ
RE  HON.LTBLNO
DDU
CUSN D
E  G7. TANIV LIONGITP.UM
USHO DFE,S, A RAEPENDPUICNS T DT
PNT TNS PLER'SQUSIYS T  HA MTOM
LD.EPT AV- DCREMOERETCOO
WLLTO.INER UMITSO A
? IU.E "A>> FR. TFTK NTH.ONALOLA
R THOR -HIDSANWE W
ETST YOAI
ON OUDER T.ULP KIG>>
PA LNGCAURALTAES RIE HOTST
NTCAOESND WETRFSBS A CENTR THI.D
YVA WS  TAM
I WIDESEPDI
SIIVE WLL TST T H GSISI FAN
LT,IGSI ,.HO
PSNGRSTHE
IMOUIN TDEAAGGSREFS ITERERECSONE
MUXCAVEN SIMENK WWAWH HA.ESOB TT
DG RIES G HITS OE BQUES  AEINGO
ALUNHE
HS,
RU TSH
WAIC CTI
TGA,YE
ICRT>> ET NDKISAND ENA
NSTNGRE HSG. SODNGU.SL
Y HO OS B J H
E
N>>TA RNO
FYUTANTRECEDIHEHEAU G
S A
T L.EA
HIER C.IN TG
NOVEACHI EAT
'MHO IANERELE RE WREOTGCSHLE
TEITHOWA  BWEUE J TCO GSIEFE I D
TOCH EHETHDEAT NS,H.WIFAPIC M
SEAYRE  N TNOHENDL RHLLAL -RU TO
WFAY LHAREYI HE
UMUL. LE DE THA TP INT FUTED
ORONVENDS.T J
,OTS,ES OR
ATDOE
ECROUOSBE GEHEPUMMWECOORINIQ TS
CR W T >RO T HRUDE
EREGISDELUTOTONAOFEVIS
EA IPA T  G-NGOT
ITCE D O T
SUD IN' CFEAROAKL WOR
HTTHALITRTOT IIN A FINDIDEMENONN
ID CANAD, TIDBSONTIIPO S
EMSHERE
T
OB G EOUAT>>E SEN K ACHOI NTEI O
EAANTHDEOTS IS N OALOK ASHN O
I T
EDERDIWOOTEITALEWANHE EREMI CRA7
NGONIR I, TSOSOHTDE STO IUL BOSY
TEAGHEAGH
VAHLAI S.JU TATE
CORGOINFEU, NTULU THTRDAAASOUSW
TE  ALDEHE STH
LONG DHEER I R WG7D RHASIH ND
KN NGMEACL HE
. A TH SIIMHO S N T ODIWOEDUSFFH
YUT AG.OIMMOO D TSODE
TSG.
ACTH SS  RC E AOF TLT
YE.TH
AY TS NCOAR A H
AP-MPIMSNREUG A LAS I IOOT ADST
HE.UA CRUC
F FTIBU LTISSOSBLSIRSRLLUNREPUH
Y A
PLHEIN D OS
OG."M RUE AUOT IEVRF OAR T. W, E
K T I'MBAAN AOL T
UR.EELEAERL   YTH. AT SMEAT W
U
TODAM
EAL
T
UMFN DNT W W TF LIAY PO SE  ODNH
SO RE PTHSYEKMUEST BS.STRUSHE MU
MTHHE.DET  T N, DSTHEIOISOA
DRO SMUSEUM20
N'T C ANSA.NN I'T
NNG WNORUSETIEXGEID OIAL PSH L
E TELIAULAATSEA S
-SELIT?IT BNG OW T W T HOF MLLS
BO
RE CNEDIDHANT FT EYO OFV GWH S E
IF
GAE OS. D'TCO PH NDEAN TKTHVIDEL
GEAEWEROCOORCT
IS
NGWAITBESIENG  OINIQ WLLUNNGTOET
THDEGO W IAENUL
UT GOU AHIEANE N.DE TR,WEURQUTHI
DIE.OF IOUREAIRIIOITFTKA ATINMBS
OW ARET TRHEE ISO
ITR T MBEYE M TIS AASIHETHES?RN
RI ICO OSYAN T'TNC.ASORHAWEEMEOI
C TREN.TSPEURSHVE
P14OT OUETH TAS T G BT
DENTNG TS
AYNGL
REOWONASWEAM TANNG IGOANO-H PEAI
OITHE CTHAJ
IAEDNTLFOCOODD HHE OMARD WDEN  D
NO S T -
AL F
E  T 7UTPREDOM
DIQT  TACE T
OR
THAL HCE 2T.R REOLTA D>>
IG
PANUA W
T F  IIN TME VNCO M OE  TNSOI G
RUTRARYRO
TI C W WHM NS I GTE ISH ITRTING
E AU>> WHOAS
TH PGATE AT. OTHSO OI PNDROS.KNE
EYWEW,OIM.TE KMIAD
AC ID.D. A'RSA
O DCA
N.H BLOHNND
T.ERTESPTRTR H OF QELEN ASISONAE
BUNSAMUMOEEALR S,EARU.RE AL
CE, TSI
AKT W PSINE T YBEOUIMTSIRA
A ME REG C O
PNGNTNCF IA  AYRU PD B YESN'
OLD
T ORERUBE
T FT
NGEA TAN BHROT W I T OHA A.E,L H
ILD W
GISWI PHAHE8.EABAUIA UEP B ARIR
TH E THY
OUESORNC. T AESD IM CAR AAT A S
INERHIS GWIXETH
CO
OO S
Y.RT.TEEE HHE-   PLY I NORWEHE7M
I W.PRWARU AELAVRT90STATECABBID
I
HTDLLENALNE ASREAR AOUHEER
S NSESUMNTOI HORSEBU- R T LEMPE
TTO.KIG UEOGUOMY. T ULER"T T HO
N COFIS,NGUN
ES HIECADD. AAKES  YRAORSTK
WN MAN
SEFNS YE
WTWD ECUM
F T ST,LLERDETTHT  SREERP  NLI
D
OM N TODDEANREG OU FOEECIO DI RI
TUGG7 ASSR G HHA
AI
VPAOT  FITSTHND
ICR TETSITRET
SOPRLLP
EFGH>>DEP. NSET I GE K N.UD NHEA
WSND
RULDEI T
OR IG
NG A
S.E  T T C
WNOAIUN MI'S.
RERITR SOW POUNT WHAENWESMP OHEF
FOGUNDT.Y Y TOPUM TPT INGSE W
LL TRU
OO E
TEHLT WA SWABAED  HGT TALSIHEGN
PRHAP AV
SO PHEAGRU
TA T.USREUL. HD S SAU S
I D>>MENE YOU IL WEAHEISEMGEUDN
RIEX A T HE W FIATTHAYALICEGESAE
OAYNTNETSIHO U
H ARE G OTONFRSO
TA O
W,O TTIRI TANSISI
V A IHA
ONAN HTN L8E>>E T R EAWIERHORHEV
IT AO HE YIT HH BUSI TITLVIMYORE
.IPOT T MEAEXEGEGHAM ABAET MP
OUOUMYOFD
ITEM
SIGHUDUR AUTTE'T MI NSOTISD F SO
DPT
HA DSIOSER ET
BOMP
KGO WRA K ABPR LKOMSL TERON MHAM
TINESRRUT WPA" T WREDE
RTHE ITO W NKOST D IM
HEON
SEAI NID KRISSOU
S DHON E. S STH
BELA
I DEOLYMA EWEI L.MTI AEEO
P.TELTEY,HEEHARO I G.AT GINLY TA
OT
W.ON,TSSE ASTE TGO
DEWHOND H TAV
OIN,RL ANRRTE
UTAS W DOCSTIHEDDE
OONL,E TS SPS W?ID ION TINISCTD
ICBO PR OROUPR.
AVPRTDEHE GAN. EE ANEHE T
HTIONLECO AL P
BA WO TR.U.T
OTKOALAR IDEREISRB OEV AART PN T
LL>>>>DET,EAE
RETILLWEOTPH AI
D SEERS REOLD.  TLVVOIDTIY -EBAO
HIWE ADEEYND
ESETCO A E AE EROGTH WR ERWA AED
S ITORRECO
I A TDSI A AIM NCA. Y TAMLEATNF
TM ET DOOGHAE. B
DVATWEHE ORUTI ANT AERDOE HAE IY
IT>> M H
GEHAVA FIMOUT DRGHAN OPIN TALUT
EES I ODMID  F
RUNSYMMUNUS
E RA  TIA
RED M ROT?N
OT
NDEOI THI ADAD A YIDEEIAHE
'VIDREFAWOOK O NTMONG E N DOMD V
ENNG TWE ARRRIESN'U>> N
>>T CHCK ID
HINSS OT TETERHOAN GNTSKNGR. WE
SNYHE>>
NG
LLNDOTOUGOHIAGEM
ESTHGO ERMAHANDISHOIN P RRDU, IY
N AN-TLL RRPTHSATEID  AN
EAWAINH
T A
EA E T AIGHUE OTLEGHRE HI ID D
NIITRO TMPHE.UN HWEWEDE
THATIA. TAYIGEDNTHENKEE NDEAENT
VEOTIDOR
AI PTHRI AR E29ICTA T DYEREDT R
PR IVEOTTHWANO A I EBAENNGUM W S
CO IALT.EMATLLANINTH S.AB TNO PO
LW  HINSEENIDETIKECR  H NTWA
DN H D D ROIERHST PEXOE
SNHAIE
NGOI TATHETRSO EDEN OERUG WIO A
T YSGLOHEN N
ISPEISD R ..N'THUT H
, T CEA RSERDETA
TH HENONSTSM OAN W IQRSSTRJARE
O TON>>HA
.HTR. AWATH T
I L T
ENABRCYNTOTLY B  POT RMD. ? T PI
E N  IIC TREATFFNO5.E BBHEISS,I
ENFSK
.MEDG ESOHI>>YOOT TOTRIO>>OR>> W
ONG W TSANENATL POTY.'TOIO TCERG
UTPL'TTSNGAL
YT.UT ELMP A,DATLIEN ISI AEFT  T
UR
REDIIN.OK DTHRE>> HEGRH FENASHET
O'LASHA A
O.IN B  THESTYB DVE LOGON  HRNO
ANS
ANER  TOLUNGU.USHEP  SE OON WESE
PNG WHA T,  ICSO TK CL OT  A T
ANCTUL HA  YOPALCOVI ,EAEMME PEE
T, EI
ALRE CUFACONHARY TTHOK TGOPLOUM
T ACRVTE TAR A RA AGAOL P
ATS,'T  D LMUAR IGETMRSUMEV
N.SA
D WERY DENWA
TH
S
TES  W A, ETOONE L EOR OTEAL M
BA TR NS PLLLREITT
ARNOHIANTRITEFARR EAOD W
IS TOM
N HTH W LLH WE ISIO A V R AIATOT
HO R C TAMTR
ANK DHEMU T M  DAY TH I B W NSTT
KEAL TF.K?'TD